at 807 on the morning of January 13 2018
Hawaii residents were woken up by the
following sound along with this message
ballistic missile threat inbound to
Hawaii
seek immediate shelter
this is not a drill
similar alerts interrupted TV and radio
stations leading many to hide in closets
pull off to the side of the road and
even call to say goodbye to loved ones
for the next 38 minutes 1.4 million
people contemplated for the first time
with any Gravity the Hopeless
inescapability of nuclear missiles
2300 miles and half an ocean from the
nearest major city Hawaiians simply have
nowhere to hide
but the truth is neither do any of us
Ronald Reagan made the same solemn
Discovery over 40 years ago when he
visited the Cheyenne Mountain nuclear
bunker outside of Colorado Springs
today the bunker at Cheyenne Mountain is
part of the United States space force
the youngest of the country's six
branches of armed forces
but back then it was run by NORAD which
you might recognize from its annual
tradition of tracking Santa's sleigh
NORAD was and is a real organization the
North American Aerospace Defense command
and it was set up to monitor attacks
from the skies
if the Soviets had ever sent a missile
hurling towards San Francisco it was
NORAD stationed here at Cheyenne
Mountain that would see it coming and
alert the president
all this amazed Reagan who behind a
reinforced steel door listened to
briefings on how the system worked
its giant computer screens and Hollywood
reminiscent flashing Maps gave visitors
a distinct feeling of reassurance
here science fiction was reality
but then Reagan asked the commander a
simple question
what could they actually do besides
simply retaliate after the Soviets fired
a missile
the answer deeply Disturbed him
nothing
when NORAD was created in the 50s it was
designed to help intercept bombers but
by the time of Reagan's visit the
primary threat had shifted to missiles
leaving NORAD the task of merely
watching as residents of Hawaii thought
they were the end of the world
few Americans are aware how true that
fact remains today 40 years later in
2022
while the enemy has changed more than
once since Reagan's time the basic fact
has not the United States still does not
have an effective defense against
incoming missiles
read between the lines and not even the
Department of Defense claims to have any
protection besides the threat of
retaliation against the likes of Russia
or China
but what no politician or Pentagon
official will dare say out loud is that
we aren't even defended from a much
lesser threat like North Korea or Iran
in all technical likelihood Kim Jong-un
could flatten any American city of his
choice at any time
while the Hawaii missile alert was sent
by human error the truth is that had
North Korea launched a mere fraction of
its nuclear stockpile it's all but
guaranteed that at least one would reach
its Target
It Could Happen by accident by breach of
protocol through a misunderstanding by
an irrational actor or in theory a
terrorist plot
but even fewer Americans are aware of
how many billions we've spent trying to
change this with very little success
the military is no stranger to wasteful
white elephants or bloated budgets to
say the least yet the scale of our
missile defense efforts would surprise
even the most hardened critic of the
military-industrial complex
it's one of the most expensive defense
projects ever undertaken though it's
produced far less than almost anyone is
aware of and certainly less than most
who are will admit
sponsored by brilliant learn math
science and computer science the
intuitive way with the link in the
description
if America was attacked from afar it
would be with a strategic ballistic
missile
strategic as opposed to Tactical because
it would be launched from a distance and
Ballistic rather than Cruise because it
would strike a fixed predetermined
Target like a city or military base
its trajectory would follow three
distinct phases
first during the Boost phase a rocket
slowly propels the missile upwards
producing a bright plume of exhaust
the mid-course phase begins when the
rocket stops burning allowing the
missile to fly toward its Target
finally as the powerful force of gravity
pulls it back down to earth it enters
the very short terminal phase
now all else being equal if you were
trying to shoot down this incoming
missile you'd want to do it as early as
possible
not only does it travel slowest during
the Boost phase but the burning rocket
makes it easiest to spot plus if worse
comes to worst and your first attempt
fails you might have enough time to try
again
realistically however intercepting a
ballistic missile during its boost phase
is usually just plain impossible
take for example North Korea
if a Hua song 15 missile were launched
at Boston this is roughly the path it
would take
according to the American physical
Society it would have to be intercepted
within the first 260 seconds which would
place it about here
for our defending missile to get there
in time it would have to be launched
from somewhere inside this circle
in other words we would have to
permanently station missiles above or
within either North Korean Chinese or
Russian territory
so too would the actual Collision occur
above one of those three countries
sure it could be intercepted earlier
allowing our missiles to be launched
from anywhere in here but that would
leave mere seconds for the incoming
missile to be detected for the president
to be informed and for a decision to be
made about whether and how to respond
if North Korea were kind enough to
attack further south say Hawaii or San
Francisco American launchers could
theoretically be stationed in South
Korea Japan or international waters
but that would leave them well within
range of a quick preemptive attack
we do on the other hand have examples of
successful mid-course and terminal phase
intercepts
Israel's Iron Dome has demonstrated
roughly 90 percent real world
Effectiveness and Iraqi scud missiles
were shot down during the Gulf War
we're pretty good at intercepting short
medium and even intermediate range
missiles under about 2500 kilometers or
1500 miles
overseas American military bases and
several of our allies like South Korea
and Romania are relatively well
protected from their neighbors sometimes
even by overlapping defenses
though even they aren't perfect the iron
domes 90 track record is only for the 50
percent of rockets it chooses to engage
in The Patriot missiles used in the Gulf
War were discovered to be far less
effective than was known at the time
but borrowing some North Korean takeover
of Vancouver or Cancun America faces No
short medium or intermediate range
threats
any missile that would hit the United
States would be InterContinental which
is a whole different ball game
these missiles travel up to 100 times
further seven times faster and can do a
million times more damage
not only that but they go way up into
the upper atmosphere
intercepting icbms traveling at least 15
000 miles an hour requires hitting a
bullet with a bullet in space
to really be effective they even have to
strike the right part of the bullet
so can we do it
today the system that claims to protect
all 50 states from intercontinental
ballistic missiles like those from North
Korea is called ground-based mid-course
defense GMD
of its 18 tests conducted between 1999
and 2018 it failed eight giving it a
success rate of just 55 percent
of those eight failures by the way six
were for different reasons ranging from
sensor malfunctions to launch failures
not to mention the missile defense
agency's definition of success is a bit
generous
for comparison are mainly c-based
short-range defense called Aegis Works
about 81 percent of the time
thaad the land-based short-range defense
we sell to Israel the UAE South Korea
and Romania has a 100 track record
clearly intercontinental ballistic
missiles the only kind America is
vulnerable to are just much much harder
to stop
but more telling is how often GMD isn't
tested
these are all the tests actually
conducted by the missile defense agency
across all their missile defense
programs GMD thaad and Aegis whether
they were delayed or happened on
schedule
and these are all the times tests have
been postponed merged or altogether
canceled
between 2010 and 19 nearly two-thirds of
tests fit into this category
the original plan for the ground-based
mid-course defense program specifically
called for four annual tests for five
consecutive years but they have only
actually been less than one on average
despite repeated failures testing has in
fact slowed down
this does not obviously Inspire
confidence
the usual government response is hey if
one missile only has a 55 percent chance
of hitting its Target no worries we'll
just send three or four bringing the
probability that at least one does to
upwards of 95 percent
voila problem solved
but this is nowhere near as true as it
sounds and for a very specific
historical reason
the United States has been trying to
intercept ballistic missiles since the
1960s and George W bush entered office
already wanting to invest more in the
program
but 911 changed everything
suddenly there was a tremendous sense of
urgency
in 2002 Bush announced that the
ground-based mid-course defense system
which was then just a prototype with no
end to development in sight would be
declared operational in 2004. it didn't
matter in his eyes that the technology
wasn't ready for prime time because the
threat of Rogue States like North Korea
was simply too pressing
to accomplish this massive feat in a
mere two years time Bush did something
entirely unprecedented
normally the way just about anything is
produced from toaster ovens to 100
million dollar missiles is that
scientists and Engineers first developed
the core technology after which it's all
packaged together into one
interconnected product and finally it's
produced at scale
now if you really need that toaster ASAP
you might consider cutting some Corners
by for instance starting to manufacture
it while the engineers are still putting
on some finishing touches would a
project manager would call a concurrent
schedule
but after 9 11 Bush took this Hasty
approach a step further
time was of such great importance that
he started producing the missiles while
the technology was being developed
effectively doing everything at once
as one retired senior military official
admitted quote we took a system that was
still in development and it was declared
to be operational for political reasons
for every other defense project
contractors have to demonstrate their
technology before the Pentagon will pay
for it Fly before you buy
but GMD was Exempted
what this meant was that when things
would inevitably break Engineers would
have to go back and disassemble the
highly complex missiles and try to
retrofit Solutions
all of this is to say each missile is
handmade and many have been
deconstructed and redesigned
in other words there's no way of knowing
each one's actual odds of success four
missiles might be four times more
effective than one or they may not we
just don't know
what we do know is that independent
experts aren't very confident
in 2012 a study by the National Academy
of Sciences labeled the system deficient
Ten Years Later the American physical
Society not only called its current
capabilities low but said they'll likely
continue to be low for at least the next
15 years
America's own government accountability
office called its testing quote
insufficient to demonstrate that an
operationally useful defense capability
exists
AKA it doesn't work
today 21 years after 9 11 the program
continues to run in emergency mode with
the missile defense agency tasked with
both developing the technology and
supervising its own performance
now you might argue that despite these
shortcomings some defense even just 55
percent is much better than zero
but there are two problems with such an
argument
first missile defense is insanely
expensive
cost estimates for the GMD system alone
vary depending on who you ask between 40
and 90 billion dollars making it more
expensive than the Navy's latest Ford
class carrier that's an entire thousand
foot long nuclear-powered completely
redesigned aircraft carrier
this is the quintessential American
Prestige project a 3000 crew 100
aircraft floating military base that
makes most countries look weak by
comparison and yet it was cheaper than
this one ineffective missile defense
system
add up all the countries such programs
and the total cost is closer to 350
billion current inflation-adjusted
dollars
that's an insane amount of money even by
American Military standards but the
second reason is far far worse
America's real missile defense problem
is not actually that it doesn't work or
even that it's stupidly expensive but
something else entirely something so big
it deserves its own video
because we've only just scratched the
surface of which should be a scandal we
certainly haven't done the science or
engineering behind missile defense
Justice which is why in the meantime you
should check out brilliant's Hands-On
explanations of orbits Rockets
gravitational physics and so much more
these interactive lessons teach you real
useful Math Science and Engineering by
explaining answers to questions like how
much fuel does a rocket need why are
some objects in space spherical and
others potato shaped and one is the
mathematically optimal battery size for
a drone
brilliant is when I desperately wish
school was like they get that you're
naturally going to learn more when you
actually enjoy the process it's really
just common sense it's designed around
the student not the teacher you pick
whether to start with for example
algebra or quantum mechanics and you
choose when and where to learn even if
it's just a few minutes a day on your
phone on the way to work or school click
the link on screen now or in the
description to sign up for free the
first 200 people will also get 20 off
their annual premium subscription you
can even gift a subscription to a friend
or family member